本日は外れしたツアーです
ん
だんだけどなんか今日も嫌な予感がするんですけども今日はちょっとガチャガチャで
面白いものを見つけたから買ってきますこちらです能面熱きっ魔除けの日目
やっぱ僕はこの部屋でいろんなことをやってきましたし心霊チックなこともやってきた
のでひょっとしたら僕の部屋を呪われているかもしれ
僕の後輩の妹ですごいベイカーの2人はいるんですけども一人かければ行った後にアン
の部屋何かゆ4一さん大丈夫
あの部屋マジでヤバいー
みたいなことを言っていたのでちょっと実は怖いですのでそういう前を系の意味も込め
て今回はの魔除けの亀井つ使っていきますこの月厚さを買いに行ったとき
どんな話題点数が起きてしまったら僕が何となくプロが撮っていたときだったこの
ガチャ月は1回300円
300円を入れて
レイバーを回すと
出てこない
戻したりもう1回していったり1回戻してから回したりしてみたのだが
ボール気配はないだがここで事件がおきたーーーーー
しばらく月外していると
600円になって帰ってきたをする c
やらせる1個開けていこうと思いますこんなの本当は買いたくないんだけどね受けって
書いてあったからなんかこう価値があったら嬉しいなと思って買っちゃいました
1個目ブーン
こと美でという名前の仮面らしい留守神様らしいですねこれは
ん
不細工魔を払う仮面と書いてあるのでもうこれを持っているだけで僕は迷うけど効果が
あります助かりますありがとうございます
なんだ今のなんか強調しておかしいなと思いかけてみましょう
でたふううううう
なんなんだろうこれじゃくせえ女っていうやつですねあー幽霊なんだこれは大メイドの
苦しみに見舞われている幽霊の顔はラス面らしいです後は
2ニッチもそれといえばこういうのに魔除けの効果がありますからとてもありがたい
です
ありがとうございます
飲んだんだよ何どんなマングス後嫌な気配を感じます今日くれず灰熊避けを踏まえお経
をあげていこう3本目いきます
はっはっ
かぶった今のところこの3種類です4つに行きましょうはっはー
のタイヤばサードのがでたぞはこれで誰だな点と千尋の神隠しなんか温泉に来た神様
みたいな顔してます黒式場俺ちょっとよくわからないんですけど怖いですね
非常に怖い顔しておりますやでもこういうのにチャだ魔除けの効果があるのでとても
ありがたい
なぜ今のストア早く魔除けは眉毛を2目立たん数にこの日はやっぱゾロはれてるよな
ま行けよ聞いてくれだめっさー
一君うっ
始め9
まっ作
me
うん頭がぁ
ドイツは何でここねずっと
なんでクオリティだすごいヴィッテルまでとビクターそっくりだ
に良い
何コレ
しています